y
vale
y hoy les voy a hablar de algo
totalmente distinto a lo que hago en el
día a día y es sobre un consejo que
seguro muchos de nosotros hemos
escuchado o por otro lado hemos dado y
es el consejo de ser tú mismo yo nací en
1988 en el seno de una familia donde
regularmente y casi como una especie de
mantra se me repetía constantemente sé
tú misma y desde muy niña se me daba
este consejo ante cualquier situación
que me causaba estrés o me causaba miedo
siempre mi mamá tenía este consejo para
mí y decía no te preocupes sé tú misma
así que desde muy temprana edad me
metieron esta idea y a mí de repente me
entró un pánico porque decía qué tal si
un día despierto y no soy yo misma qué
tal si un día me veo al espejo y ya no
soy fernanda soy otra persona y de
verdad había días que tenía pesadillas
despertaba me veía el espejo y no era yo
misma y eso me daba muchísimo terror así
que me comencé a hacer una pregunta y es
cómo podría dejar de ser yo misma o cómo
podría no ser yo misma o incluso cabe la
posibilidad de que un día no sea yo
misma y así estuve pensándolo pensándolo
pero la primera vez que realmente me dio
mucho miedo de no ser yo misma es cuando
puse me puse a pensar que siempre
tenemos esta idea de intentar satisfacer
las cosas que tienen nuestros padres
nuestra pareja de nuestros amigos y
realmente ahí es cuando perdemos o
stamos tambaleantes a hacer nosotros
mismos porque este tipo de expectativas
nos dan como la entrada al miedo de
decir híjole es que quiero hacer esto
pero que va a decir mi familia o que va
a decir mi vecino o que va a decir mi
pareja porque aunque seamos los más
rebelde
el mundo aunque digamos que pensamos
fuera de la caja y que vivimos a nuestro
placer
tarde o temprano sale de nuestra
naturaleza como ser humanos como
animales sociales esta necesidad de
aprobación esta necesidad de encajar
porque claro a quien no le gusta estar
en un grupo social de amigos de vecinos
de compañeros de clase nos encanta
sentirnos parte de algo más grande de
algo más trascendente y la primera vez
que yo tuve este sentimiento de no
encajar cual si fuera una pieza de ron
que rompecabezas fue en el kinder y fue
algo que me trauma de por vida estaba yo
desde niño me encantaba atraparme a los
árboles jugar con la tierra a sacar las
lombrices y eso me parecía fabuloso así
que cuando fui al kinder pues seguía
actuando de esa manera es para mi era
normal y de pronto me topo con un grupo
de niñas que estaban pasando la
increíble jugando algo que se llamaba la
rueda
sanmiguel y entonces me acerco y les
pido permiso para poder jugar con ellas
y muy tajantemente una niña con esa
sinceridad que nos caracteriza a estos
años de edad me dijo no tú no puedes
jugar porque no está haciendo una niña
normal y yo si no mi pesadilla de no ser
yo misma se convirtió en realidad
y hoy me da risa pero en ese momento
provocó en mí tanto sufrimiento que
llegué a mi casa llorando y le decía a
mi mamá mamá una niña en la escuela me
dijo que no estaba siendo una niña de
verdad que está pasando no mi mamá en su
sabiduría de madre me dijo no te
preocupes sé tú misma y yo decide pues
por eso está haciendo el problema porque
estoy siendo yo misma y al parecer ser
uno mismo resulta fundamental en una
sociedad como la que hoy tenemos
pareciera que todo el mundo dice este
consejo a diestra y siniestra como si
fuera una especie de fórmula de vida que
realmente si lo pensamos con claridad
cada uno de nosotros incluso los que
estamos aquí reunidos tenemos una
percepción totalmente distinta de lo que
significa ser uno mismo cada uno tiene
sus propias creencias valores miedos
circunstancias que nos llevan a tener
distintas percepciones sobre lo que
significa ser uno mismo y así que ser
uno mismo si intentáramos sintetizar los
y todos
vamos ponernos de acuerdo en lo que
realmente significa quizás podríamos
intentarlo a través de entender que es
una cuestión de individualidad y de
unicidad pero sobre todo es una cuestión
de construcción todo el tiempo es decir
nunca terminas de ser tú mismo todo el
tiempo estamos en construcción todo el
tiempo estamos cambiando de forma de ser
porque las circunstancias cambian porque
el contexto cambia porque nosotros y
nuestros intereses nuestras prioridades
van cambiando con el tiempo y lo que hoy
te parece genial quizás en 20 años vas a
decir cómo es que eso me gustaba y no es
porque esté mal simplemente es porque es
parte de ser tú mismo y de esta
construcción qué significa el ser humano
de hecho cuando nacemos traemos muy poca
información precargada tuve siendo tú
mismo conforme va pasando el tiempo y
esta historia que les cuento de la niña
en el kinder que me dijo con este trauma
solamente fue ese momento sino después
cuando estaba en la adolescencia me di
cuenta que este tema de ser yo mismo me
estaba afectando incluso en mi núcleo
familiar es decir yo quería tomar
ciertas decisiones por ejemplo no sé
estudiar teatro quería dedicarme a la
actuación por completo quería estudiar
en la universidad nacional autonoma de
mexico
quería explorar otras religiones y quise
incluso jugar fútbol a nivel profesional
en cada uno de estos escenarios me topé
con una realidad que me dolía muchísimo
y es sí sí sí sí puedes ser tú misma
pero no haciendo esas cosas y entonces
este consejo que se volvió parte de mi
vida de repente me puso de frente una
verdad que dije oye pero me estás
haciendo por un lado que sea yo misma
pero por otro lado me dices que no
haciendo esas cosas entonces realmente
qué significa y ahí a los 15 años pensé
qué pasa cuando ser tú mismo va en
contra del status
contra de lo que te han enseñado de lo
que quizás en la escuela ha aprendido o
lo que tus papás incluso te han
inculcado qué pasa con eso y me di
cuenta de una realidad porque
afortunadamente comencé a trabajar muy
joven y convivir con personas más
grandes que yo y entonces me di cuenta
que hay muchas cualidades o habilidades
que admiramos en terceros pero que si
las tenemos en las personas cercanas nos
da un poco de miedo incluso esta
repulsión por ejemplo pensemos en la
incertidumbre o si es esta actualidad de
intentar manejar el miedo y estar como
inconforme y si leemos las biografías de
los personajes más exitosos que han
atravesado en la humanidad la
inconformidad pareciera que es una
cualidad que te ayuda a tener éxito y
cuando él es inconforme decimos que
bueno que no se dejó qué bueno que
reclamó esto qué
que no se conforme y que cambia las
cosas pero cuando las tenemos cercanas
es cuando realmente decimos ay no no
está tan padre si el inconforme es decir
por un lado idolatramos ciertas
habilidades en la cultura popular pero
por otro lado si alguien cercano las
tiene intentamos cambiarlo y decir no no
no no seas así tienes que ser normal y
entonces esto contradice el discurso
otro ejemplo podría ser el tema de
asumir el riesgo de ser amantes del
riesgo ser amantes del riesgo es lo que
ha llevado hoy a compañías como el bien
bieber y todas esas que conocemos al
éxito y decimos que padres si están
logrando conquistar el mundo y están ahí
siendo exitosas pero si alguien de
nuestro círculo inmediato es amante del
riesgo y no vamos lejos pensemos en
alguien que dice oye yo no quiero
trabajar en una empresa quiero ser
freelance es como no no no no como como
que freelance mejor vete a una empresa
donde estés seguro donde no tengas que
riesgos
y ahí entra nuestro doble discurso de
adorar a estas cualidades y por otro
lado rechazarlas y podríamos poner
ejemplos muy puntuales como el caso de
steve jobs que ya lo hemos platicado
seguramente en muchísimas charlas pero
el punto aquí es pensar en lo que más se
admiraba del que era su creatividad de
innovación y eso está muy bien pero hay
otra historia en donde dice que si
efectivamente su creatividad era tanta
que es un nivel de exigencia era casi
enfermo que le gritaba a sus empleados
así que qué pasa que si es tibio fuera
tu jefe y fuera el que te grita y te
exige al máximo seguramente hoy estaría
demandado porque ya no se tolera en este
tipo de prácticas y eso está bien sin
embargo otro ejemplo claro es lo que hoy
estamos viviendo coyunturalmente esta
chica que podríamos estar a favor o en
contra y esa es otra discusión sin
embargo mucha gente lo que admira es su
fortaleza su entereza
y su capacidad de hablar en el público
pero qué pasaría si fuera tu hija la que
dice que va a renunciar a la escuela
para defender al planeta
las circunstancias cambiarían y entonces
quizás tu discurso también cambiaría
porque si fuera tan fácil y tan sexy
como a mí me hicieron creer y segura
muchas personas más que ser tú mismo es
la clave para triunfar en la vida pues
muchas personas estarían siendo ellas
mismas y haciendo lo que realmente les
gusta y había habría muchas personas muy
felices pero sabemos que no y de hecho
el interés por ser uno mismo ha
descendido con el tiempo y si no me
creen vean la siguiente tabla esta es
una herramienta que se llama google
trends y lo que yo me puse a investigar
es cuántas búsquedas ha habido del 2004
para acá sobre cómo ser tú mismo o how
to be yourself y si se dan cuenta en el
2004 habría muchas personas queriendo
ser ellas mismas y por alguna razón eso
se cayó con el tiempo y esos piquitos
que ven ahí son estas temporadas
decembrinas donde a todos nos pasa no
por así voy a estar yo mismo
pero esta historia que les contaba sobre
mi infancia mi adolescencia
evidentemente no terminó ahí toqué fondo
como muchas de las historias que seguro
van a escuchar acá y me tocar fondo fue
cuando tomé una de las peores decisiones
en mi vida que al mismo tiempo se
convirtió en la mejor y es me casé muy a
muy temprana edad y me casé porque tenía
esta necesidad de satisfacer a mis
padres que vieran que si estaba siendo
yo misma y que si estaba haciendo yo
misma conforme su código de creencias y
entonces para que me dejaran en paz y ya
no me dijeran que fuera yo misma dije
bueno voy a hacer lo que se supone que
debo hacer me voy a casar voy a tener
una familia pero justo un día antes de
mi boda me entró un pánico en donde yo
sentía en lo más profundo de mis
entrañas que eso no estaba bien que lo
que iba a hacer era totalmente
equivocado así que hablé con mi mamá y
le dije a mamá no quiero hacerlo
y ella me dijo no te preocupes son los
nervios de la boda todo el mundo lo
siente y una vez más emitió su sabio
consejo y me dijo sé tú misma
así que yo esa noche que no dormí dije
es que esto es justamente no sé yo estoy
atacando me estoy saboteando me estoy
yendo contra mí misma y aún así lo hice
porque quizás pensé que el miedo se iba
a quitar mi matrimonio duró lo que dura
un estornudo pero eso me trajo un
aprendizaje realmente cuando yo me dije
nunca más voy a permitir que esta
intuición que me dijo que eso no era lo
correcto no le voy a volver a hacer caso
es más hoy más que nunca le voy a hacer
caso y entonces se preguntarán está mal
ser uno mismo según yo la respuesta es
no pero el tema es que no nos han
contado la historia completa sobre ser
uno mismo no nos dan un manual de aquí
siga los diez pasos para ser uno mismo y
es porque realmente no existe
pero la historia incompleta de esta
historia es que nunca me dijeron que ser
yo mismo iba a traer consecuencias y
estas consecuencias fueron para bien y
para mal en mi vida así que me di cuenta
que para ser uno mismo
necesitamos autoconocimiento y
autoconsciencia saber no se escuchará
entonces yo me formule como este camino
para poder ser uno mismo y no significa
que esto vaya a funcionar para todos
ustedes pero sí puede ser un parteaguas
y es la otra parte de la historia que
casi nunca nos cuenta nadie cuando nos
da el consejo de ser tú mismo y el
primer punto es abrazado oscuridad eso
es muy importante porque vivimos en un
mundo donde sólo se piensa que lo bueno
o lo de luz y eso está muy padre y está
bien yo no estoy defendiendo lo
contrario sin embargo si tenemos que
admitir y saber que hay una parte oscura
y densa en nuestra humanidad y está bien
es parte de nosotros todos los artistas
que admiramos pensemos en el arte
pensemos en van gogh tuvieron estos
momentos de oscuridad y esa
generaron sus mejores obras y es porque
la oscuridad es una forma de energía que
si la transformas la conoces y la
trabaja se puede convertir en una gran
obra de arte el paso número 2 es nunca
terminas ya lo dije al inicio siempre
estás en beta es que eres como una
inacabada que siempre está en
actualización y está bien está bien que
sea así
nunca estás en la meta porque quizás el
día que llega hasta la meta this is a
store a todo y entonces te buscas una
nueva meta el tercer punto es va a doler
y esto no es una amenaza simplemente es
una advertencia porque vas a tener que
renunciar a cosas vas a tener que elegir
unas y discriminar otras y seguramente
en el camino perder personas y perder
muchas cosas pero eso te va a dar con el
tiempo grandes satisfacciones y el
cuarto punto es resiste hay más como tú
es más todos los que hoy estamos aquí de
alguna forma u otra estamos intentando
construir nos y ser nosotros mismos y si
esto no hubiese funcionado
si esta fórmula no me hubiese funcionado
seguramente hoy yo no estaría aquí con
ustedes así que los invito a que
disfrutemos de nosotros mismos y del
camino que estamos construyendo en el
proceso de ser nosotros mismos pero
sobre todo algo muy importante que creo
que hoy más que nunca en el contexto
social que vivimos hace falta y es la
empatía se nos olvida que todo el mundo
está intentando encontrarle sentido a su
propia existencia y se nos olvida que
somos humanos y que podemos fallar en el
camino y que eso está bien y que quizás
el otro está tomando actitudes que no me
gustan pero yo no sé qué hay en su
cabeza que hay en su contexto y que lo
hace actuar de esa manera así que seamos
más empáticos y la próxima vez que le
demos a alguien el consejo que tú mismo
pensemos en las implicaciones que eso
tiene muchas gracias
[Aplausos]